[Música]
a tan sólo 20 km de moscú mataron a la
hija de uno de los aliados del
presidente vladimir putin cuando ya eran
extraños los ataques contra las personas
cercanas al kremlin la ira divina murió
cuando el vehículo en el que iba explotó
singapur despenalizar a las relaciones
sexuales entre hombres pues el primer
ministro les jianlong anunció que el
gobierno derogará una ley de la era
colonial sin embargo en el país sigue
siendo prohibido el matrimonio entre
personas del mismo sexo
perú enciende las alertas por el
desgaste de machu picchu las autoridades
se han reunido con empresarios y
habitantes del sector para convenir una
manera de proteger el patrimonio
histórico luego de las protestas tras la
recomendación de la unesco de reducir
los visitantes diarios
bienvenidos a las noticias
internacionales aquí en france 24 yo soy
maría clara calle y es un placer estar
de nuevo con ustedes
comenzamos en rusia allí mataron a la
hija de uno de los aliados del
presidente vladimir putin
dayra dubina murió luego de que el
vehículo en el que se transportaba
explotó la agencia estatal de noticias
rusa estás señala que el objetivo del
ataque pudo haber sido su padre
alexander dubín un nacionalista que ha
defendido la unificación de los
territorios de habla rusa bajo un solo
imperio por su parte las autoridades
ucranianas señalan que no tienen nada
que ver con el atentado samuel salgado
nos amplía el vehículo en el que viajaba
daria dukina explotó en la noche del
sábado a 40 kilómetros de moscú la hija
del ideólogo ultra nacionalista ruso
alexander du king un cercano aliado de
vladimir putin murió en el lugar las
autoridades rusas ya abrieron una
investigación por homicidio en este
momento los investigadores y
especialistas forenses del comité de
investigación de rusia así como expertos
en bombas trabajo en la escena del
crimen
alexander iba a viajar en ese vehículo y
a última hora cambio de planes por lo
que la familia considera que él era el
blanco del supuesto ataque
doguín seguidor del eurasia mismo
corriente política que concibe a rusia
como el centro de una civilización
expresó abiertamente su apoyo a
reunificar todos los territorios de
habla rusa mucho en el contexto de la
invasión de rusia ucrania el kremlin
responsabiliza a kiev si se confirma el
rastro craneano entonces debemos hablar
de la política de terrorismo de estado
llevado a cabo por el régimen de kiev el
gobierno de volodymyr selenski desmintió
estar detrás del ataque y por el
contrario advirtió que teme una ofensiva
por parte del ejército ruso el 24 de
agosto cuando además de cumplirse seis
meses desde la invasión se conmemora el
día de la bandera ucraniana
alexander dogging está sancionado desde
2015 por eeuu por amenazar la paz
seguridad y soberanía territorial de
ucrania tras la anexión de la península
de crimea mientras que su hija
periodista y politóloga y nueve años
estaba sancionada por tener un medio de
desinformación líderes de occidente
hicieron un llamado para que no haya
operaciones militares cerca de la planta
nuclear de sap orilla la más grande de
europa downing street- la oficina del
primer ministro británico boris johnson
explicó que hoy el premier tuvo una
llamada telefónica con sus homólogos de
francia alemania y eeuu en ella johnson
emanuel mayo olaf scholz y joe biden
recalcaron la importancia de proteger
las instalaciones nucleares y se
mostraron a favor de que el organismo
atómico de la onu visite la central para
evaluar su estado también reiteraron que
seguirán apoyando a ucrania
y mientras tanto el reino unido
continúan las huelgas en el sector del
transporte hoy los trabajadores
portuarios se unieron al paro que ya
había comenzado los empleados
ferroviarios desde esta semana exigen un
aumento salarial acorde con la inflación
rampante
mientras los viajes se paralizan en
plena temporada de vacaciones
felixstowe suele ser el mayor puerto de
mercancías del reino unido- ahora está
detenido cerca de 2.000 trabajadores
portuarios iniciaron este domingo una
huelga de ocho días que podría paralizar
el tráfico de mercancías en el país la
acción se produce después de dos días de
huelga de los trabajadores ferroviarios
para reclamar mejores salarios tienen
que encontrar otro camino porque
perturban a todo el país inmensamente me
alegro de que la gente tenga la
oportunidad de exponer su punto de vista
pero claro los que sufrimos somos
nosotros no los que van a trabajar en
sus limusinas y taxis negros el viernes
fueron los trabajadores del metro de
londres quienes entraron en huelga
reclaman entre otras cosas una subida
salarial ante la galopante inflación en
el reino unido- la subida de los precios
superó el 10 por ciento en julio un
récord en 40 años
por primera vez desde la década de 1950
es probable que los británicos se
enfrenten a restricciones alimentarias
cortes de electricidad y escasez de
calefacción exclusión por el momento las
negociaciones entre el gobierno y los
sindicatos y siguen en un punto muerto y
la protesta podría seguir creciendo
seguiremos hasta conseguir un acuerdo
que apoyen nuestros miembros estamos en
esta disputa porque no tenemos otra
opción estamos siendo atacados por las
empresas y por el gobierno un conflicto
social que tendrá que resolver el
próximo primer ministro en la carrera la
conservadora listos y rígidos unac ros
la favorita es conocida por su
liberalismo económico y se ha
comprometido a presentar una legislación
para restringir aún más el derecho de
huelga este domingo se cumplen 500 días
desde que el periodista francés olivia
tuba fue secuestrado por yihadistas
mientras informaba desde malí muchos
siguen instando al gobierno francés a
que haga más para garantizar su
liberación para y sostiene que está
plenamente comprometido en conseguir la
liberación de eduba a pesar de que todas
las tropas francesas ya salieron del
país africano desde el pasado lunes
hace un año y medio el periodista
francés olivier fue secuestrado en mali
por él jn y emme un grupo extremista
vinculado a al-qaeda el periodista
freelance secuestrado el 8 de abril de
2021 había estado informando para varios
medios de comunicación en malí y francia
sus familiares no han tenido noticias de
él pero tuvo ha sido visto en vídeos de
propaganda difundidos por sus captores
su familia pide a los franceses que
envíen una petición al elíseo exigiendo
la liberación de dubai usted y busca mi
hermano muere un poco más día a día en
el desierto olivié permanece en nuestra
mente a diario cada hora cada minuto y
segundo sus personalidades públicas e
incluso antiguos rehenes se han
pronunciado pidiendo la liberación de
olivia
el gobierno francés dice estar
plenamente comprometido con la
liberación del periodista incluso
después de que su fuerza abarcan se
retirará de malí el 15 de agosto la
condición es la discreción es un
elemento esencial para cualquier acción
que el estado lleve a cabo en zonas que
son peligrosas y delicadas sabemos que
hay negociaciones en curso y esperamos
que estas conversaciones discretas
desemboquen en la libertad de libia
racionalista el sábado olivier huguá
celebró su cumpleaños número 48 en
cautiverio
el nuevo reporte del ministerio de salud
de somalia confirmó que 21 personas
murieron tras el asedio de militantes
vinculados a al-qaeda en un hotel de la
capital mogadiscio además 117 personas
resultaron heridas decenas de civiles
fueron tomados como rehenes en el hotel
hyatt durante 30 horas contadas desde el
viernes cuando los atacantes de al
shabab se tomaron el edificio las
autoridades terminaron el asedio aunque
aclaran que la cifra de muertos puede
subir
y singapur despenalizará el sexo entre
hombres según lo anunció el primer
ministro les jianlong aunque reconoció
que la sociedad acepta cada vez más a
los homosexuales enfatizó que el
gobierno no tiene la intención de
cambiar el único concepto de matrimonio
que se permite legalmente que es el de
un hombre y una mujer hasta ahora las
relaciones sexuales masculinas eran
prohibidas por un código penal de la era
de la colonia
un día histórico para la comunidad lgbt
en singapur 15 años después del último
debate sobre la posible derogación de la
ley que penaliza las relaciones sexuales
entre hombres el primer ministro lee
hsien loong cumplió con sus promesas
esta vez en su discurso político anual
el gobierno de drogar a la sección 37 7a
y despenalizar a el sexo entre hombres
creo que esto es lo correcto algo que la
mayoría de los singapurenses aceptar
ahora
la ley herencia del dominio colonial
británico prevé una pena máxima de dos
años de prisión a hombres que tengan
relaciones sexuales con otros hombres en
la práctica no se aplica pero para sus
partidarios el texto priva a los
miembros de la comunidad gay de sus
derechos en esta ciudad de estado
conservador a varios intentos de anular
la ley habían fracasado durante los
últimos años en contraste con la
situación de los derechos de los
homosexuales en asia en taiwán el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
es legal desde 2019 y en índia el sexo
entre hombres está despenalizado desde
2018 por lo tanto el anuncio fue bien
recibido por varias asociaciones
la despenalización no sólo mejorará la
vida de las personas lgbt pumas y sus
familias sino que traerá otros
beneficios claros para los negocios el
comercio y la reputación internacional
de singapur lo que hace que este anuncio
sea bienvenido en muchos frentes
pero el primer ministro de singapur
también anunció que proteger a la
concepción del matrimonio entre un
hombre y una mujer definida por la ley
el gobierno enmendar a pronto la
constitución para que el matrimonio
civil siga estando dedicado únicamente a
la unión de dos personas de diferentes
sexos el papá francisco finalmente se
pronunció sobre la situación de los
representantes de la iglesia católica en
nicaragua donde en los últimos meses se
han avivado las detenciones a sacerdotes
y obispos unas declaraciones que
llegaron después de que el obispo de
matagalpa rolando álvarez fuera
arrestado el viernes el reporte desde
manuel a cara
el vaticano rompe el silencio
dos días después de que rolando álvarez
el obispo de matagalpa un municipio en
el centro de nicaragua y crítico del
presidente nicaragüense daniel ortega
fuera detenido el papá francisco
finalmente se pronunció se guarda vicino
con preocupaciones y dolores sigo de
cerca con preocupación y dolor la
situación que tiene lugar en nicaragua
que involucra a personas instituciones
o leyes primera convención en el
expresar mi convicción y mi deseo de que
a través de un diálogo abierto y sincero
se puedan encontrar las bases para una
convivencia respetuosa y pacífica
la declaración llega tras las críticas a
las máximas autoridades de la iglesia
católica de permanecer ajenas a la
situación en el país centroamericano en
donde la persecución a sus
representantes por parte del gobierno de
daniel ortega es recurrente álvarez fue
detenido por supuestas acciones
desestabilizadoras y provocadoras junto
a cinco sacerdotes una ola de arrestos
que encendió las alarmas a nivel
internacional la organización de estados
y el consejo episcopal de américa latina
y el caribe y la onu condenaron los
hechos
las voces de rechazo se escucharon desde
costa rica donde reside una amplia
comunidad de nicaragüenses en el exilio
iglesia católica por parte de la vida
ortega ha catalogado a los obispos de
terroristas por su mediación en un
diálogo nacional que pretendía buscar
una solución a la crisis que atraviesa
el país desde 2018 año en el que explotó
el descontento social en las calles el
mandatario asegura que se trató de un
complot entre la oposición en eeuu para
destituirlo bajo la complicidad de los
sacerdotes
en perú el ministerio de cultura
advirtió que machu picchu una de las
siete maravillas del mundo está en
peligro de desgaste y no sólo por el
tiempo sino también porque muchos
visitantes tocan o se apoyan en las
paredes incas incluso la unesco
recomiendo reducir la cantidad de
visitantes una idea que ha despertado
las protestas de los locales
una de las siete maravillas del mundo
está en alerta la ministra de cultura de
perú betsy chávez advirtió que el
desgaste de machu picchu debería
preocupar no solo a los peruanos sino a
toda la humanidad en efecto hizo un
llamado a la conciencia lo que queremos
pedirles más bien a toda la ciudadanía a
todos nuestros hermanos turistas
nacionales y extranjeros es que
protejamos el patrimonio cultural esta
semana se han producido protestas en
aguascalientes ciudad desde la cual se
accede a la ciudad de la inca así como
debates sobre el aforo del lugar puesto
que la unesco recomienda una cifra de
visitantes diarios que no es compartida
por trabajadores de la zona en la región
en la que se encuentra el complejo
arqueológico existe un aforo autorizado
de cuatro mil cuarenta y cuatro personas
sin embargo en julio pasado la unidad de
gestión aprobó el incremento de la
cabida en machu picchu en mil espacios
esto para permitir la reactivación de
sus actividades duramente golpeadas
desde el inicio de la pandemia de kobe
19 pero el aumento en la demanda amenaza
su preservación
y pone en evidencia la necesidad de un
turismo sostenible y tenemos que
trabajar el tema de manera transversal
por un lado la protección del patrimonio
porque sin patrimonio no hay turismo
pero es importante también inyectar
estas palabras de turismo responsable el
lunes 15 de agosto la ministra se reunió
con el gobernador regional de cusco el
alcalde de machu picchu y con
representantes de los gremios que se
encargan del sector turístico en esta
región para impulsar nuevos acuerdos en
pro de salvaguardar el patrimonio
peruano y a propósito de perú 51 parejas
se casaron a orillas del lago titicaca
los novios realizaron rituales
ancestrales y ofrendas a la tierra para
pedir una vida buena feliz y próspera
les deseamos todo lo mejor
hasta aquí las noticias sigan en france
[Música]